On the 11th of February,
I discover,
I discover my fiance
cheating on me with >> Let's go.
Let's [__] go.
>> My best friend of 10 years. >> Oh no. My god.
I'm making this. [music] >> Oh no. Oh no.
Oh no.
Chibi Reviews did a video. Archive this immediately.
Get this archived now.
>> This video
as more of a statement to myself.
>> So, sorry to cut this in in the middle of that segment
though, but this is actually critical. Now, if you guys missed
it earlier today, Chibi Reviews is having a bit of a meltdown,
and I don't know what this video is going to be, but it is crazy.
Okay, I think it's going to be crazy. Oh, there's a Shimu tweet
as well. I was just looking at the Chibi Reviews Twitter, but
give me a second. There's a Shimu tweet. What's the Shimu tweet?
These were the tweets he had. I want to die. And then he posted
apparently a video of him in the hospital and said, "I I was
about to die, but I was saved at the last moment." And then he
said, "I just lost my fiance, my best friend, and my entire friend
group in 24 hours. I've never been more alone than right now."
And that was not 51 minutes ago. It's probably what, four or
five hours ago now, and now he's just posted a video. So,
uh, this is actually 10 hours ago, and now he's posted a video.
This is, uh, this video is for me to process everything and to
give closure to myself. I leave it as a record of everything
that happened for I can try to put my life back in order. This
post makes it final to accept everything and come to terms with
everything.
I if this isn't bait, this is going to be a crazy video. Okay,
this is going to be absolutely in the insane video.
Chibi reviews
spirals into madness.
Exclamation point.
God, is Chibi Reviews really going to lose it? I I'm a little
worried. I'm a little scared that this might just be bait. Okay,
I feel like there's a chance that this is just bait and that
would be tremendously disappointing to me. Where did I put this
from the video? Here it is. Okay, I really hope it's not just
bait. I hope it's something sincere cuz I not cuz I hate this
guy, but genuinely I just feed off of other people's negative
emotion and I need something to perk me up right now so I can
play WoW for about eight hours after this. So, I need the energy.
Please feed me your misery right now, Chibi Reviews. I'm Please,
Chibi Reviews, feed me your misery. Please feed me your misery.
That's a joke, by the way. It's uh not actually true, but >> this
video is for me. >> Sometimes watching people suffer is
okay. But
then I get into it. If he actually cries, and I I literally you
can see the the tears. Okay. If he actually cries, I might lose
it. I might lose my ability to really enjoy. Hold on.
Right. You can see you see the tear duct starting to go. You
see the flare from the from the tears. Okay.
>> There. Oh, hold on.
>> I'm making this video. >> He was just crying before
he started.
>> You can see literally his eyes are watering. You can
see that his he's got like the wetness under his eyes. Okay.
a statement to myself.
This video is for me
[sighs]
to put all my
my thoughts together and
work things out in my own way because one of the ways I've always
um
gotten through trauma
and hardships in my life, especially in these last years, is
to just focus on work. >> Keep making content
>> Yeah. Oh, just keep making content. Yeah, just hit hit
the button. Hit the >> Make videos.
It's the only
joy
[snorts] that I really have.
you all saw the post. You all have seen
>> We did. >> You've seen what I've said in the last
24 how many hours? I don't know. This is
I'm just going to give you a a full rundown of just everything
that >> Oh no, cuz >> that happened.
>> Oh no. But yes. Yes. But also Oh no.
So if you missed it guys, I will go back to the Twitter one more
time before we continue on with this content. So if you think
about this, what do you have to do to lose your fiance, your
best friend, and your entire friend group? I feel like this is
cheating on your fiance, right? Gotta be
cheating on your fiance, hitting your fiance, literally touching
a kid. Like, these are the things you'd have to do to lose your
your friends and your fiance at the same time. There's only a
handful of things you could do to actually have this happen.
And he apparently is going to bear all. It's a tell all moment.
Okay,
>> maybe I'm oversharing.
This will be used against me to mock me or whatever.
>> 100%. The first the first response under Hold on. Let
me go as as reference for this. Let me go to the first response
under just lost my fiance, my best friend in my entire friend
group in 24 hours. I have never been more alone than right now.
As a reference, let us go to the first response. Here it is.
Oh, it's not anymore. It was Sorry, this was when I came up.
No,
it was this. This was the first response I got when I was looking
at this. Okay, this is literally the top the top of the response
list was this.
it will be used against you. Yes, it will be used against you.
I I saw it and I'm like, yeah, yeah, that's that's what's going
to happen, man. That's what's going to happen. It do be like
that. I wish the internet was a I'm like PPP right now. Okay.
I wish the internet was a different place, dude. I wish the I
WISH THE INTERNET WERE A DIFFERENT I'm trying to get PPP's voice.
Hold on. I wish it were different, man. I wish it were different.
I can't do it. It's actually too close to my own voice to really
really make a differentiation. Um, I wish it were different on
the internet. Okay. I wish it were different, but that's how
the internet is. That's how the internet is, man. >> PPP.
Oh, if you don't know who it is, don't worry. >> I said
I'm saying all this just
to clear my head. Just because if I say it,
it's it's done. It's it's over. Like I'm able to just process
everything at least a little bit better.
on the 11th of February,
I discover
your fiance's been cheating on you. What did he do to his fiance
after she cheated on him? I discovered my fiance
cheating on me with >> LET'S GO.
THAT WAS the easiest answer. That was the easiest answer. Okay,
[laughter] let's [__] go.
>> My best friend of 10 years.
>> Oh my god.
Oh sh Oh, where is it? >> Oh [__] Oh [__]
>> With his best friend of 10 years. That's
That's a tough one. That's That is a tough one. Okay.
That's That's rough.
That That actually defeats the entire
Oh, best friend and wife are the same thing. Best friend and
fiance are the same person narrative. We thought maybe We thought
maybe it was possible that all three were the same entity. Okay,
his entire friend group, his best friend and his fiance, all
of it was just one person. This sort of beats that narrative.
K.
Now, how do he lose the entire friend group? Cuz to me, you got
to do some entire you got to do some crazy ass to make the friend
group side with the cheaters. Okay. To me, the friend group all
knows, "Yeah, [__] the cheaters. We're going to be
friends with these people, with this guy, right?"
[snorts] I confronted her about this and
she apologized and
being with her already for multiple years and then finding out
my best
So much betrayal.
that's a tough one.
So, what I decided to do
is just
grab my keys.
I went driving.
>> I Bro, I'm sorry. I'm sorry. This is the hand. Thank
you. This is the hand. Okay.
This is the hand of the person that he was dating. And I'm just
like,
bro,
>> I'm sorry. You can tell from the hand alone. You can
literally tell from the hand alone. This is this is what I was
talking about. Okay. That like the calipers, they're not going
to work.
This is some hoofs. Okay. [laughter]
Anyway, anyway, anyway, we get back to the video. We get back
to the video.
>> I went to the liquor store.
I bought alcohol. That was the same
The last alcohol.
>> Oh, wait. Hold on. His brother. No way. That did he
buy the same drink as his
I drank when my brother
>> Oh, when that he drank when his brother
did it. Okay. >> And then I drove
into the middle of nowhere
near water
and I drank
and drank
just just sitting there drinking.
Hold on. I might need to Do we need Hold
And I was
from death.
then suddenly
a police officer shows up.
Don't know how I was found,
but he shows up
he saved me at the last moment.
He did.
And I come to find out
after all this, it was Nick, Nicholas Light, that was the one
that apparently
called a wellness check on me.
Wait, hold on. Nicholas Light wouldn't be his best friend, would
it? There's no way Nicholas Light is his best friend, is it?
Who? Who? Wait, do should we know who his best friend is in the
whole world?
>> And he he saved my life. He I I
He saved He saved my life. [laughter] >> God God damn it,
Nicholas. Did we really need I already had a hundred reasons
to hate this Nicholas Light guy. Did I really need 101? [laughter]
Anyways, the officer escorted me to
escorted me to the hospital
because obviously with everything, making sure mental evaluation
and all that
and I obviously couldn't drive, you know, too much alcohol.
he uh took me to um
the hospital and I stayed basically the night and I wasn't able
to access my phone or use anything
until they discharged me.
I got discharged earlier this morning
was so hurt.
give I want to give full context.
Thank you.
[snorts]
all I can say is at this point his friends are monsters. Okay?
[laughter] Like his friends that he got cheated on. It was his
best friend and his wife or his fiance, sorry. And the rest of
the friend group are like, "Yeah, we're gonna chill with them."
Actually,
his friends are animals. I'm getting messaged somehow.
Nicholas Light has my number.
He saved me. It's fine. And then Tech Tone, apparently he he
gives me a call as well. And
they're worried about me.
>> And
so many others reached out
that I didn't [laughter] the the Oh, I closed the video. We got
the whole podcast back in the house, guys.
It must It must have been Oh, yeah. We We'll keep going. Okay.
Thank you.
I do. I do. just
hell. [snorts] Anyways,
I get picked up and I'm going home.
Like, I'm free to go. Everything's fine.
And I knew I had to tackle the elephant in the room. [sighs and gasps]
I had to
go home.
So he abused his wife. Then he tackled the elephant. He literally
abused his wife. Okay.
Yeah. So I mean I'm just saying obviously that's why the friend
group split. He is confessing to tackling his
It's pretty obvious to me. I think we can all see it, right?
>> Like I'm free to go. Everything's fine.
And I knew I had to tackle the elephant in the room. I had to
go home and
more or less
I confronted her about everything, trying to talk
she left.
I'm not a perfect person. I make mistakes and I I know I pick
people off.
I annoy them.
But
my [gasps and sighs]
anyways, after she after she left
do what anyone probably would reasonally do. I wanted to confined
in someone.
Not
I go
to my gaming friend group that I've known
just as long
as my best friend that
my ex my my my
cheated with.
I talk with them
and
they straight up
they admit to me they don't care
[laughter] what my used to be best friend did.
Dude, [laughter] dude. Dude,
why? Dude, they hate this guy. That's crazy. I can't imagine,
man. They prefer
>> with him and I thought these guys were my friends. I
I did >> and they more or less they just cared about gaming
with him and they didn't care about everything. They're completely
okay. >> Bro, you're a [__] you're a Spider-Man
man. Okay, I we didn't want to say it but we hate playing with
you. Okay, you Spider-Man blood one trick. Get the out of here,
man. pay with
And so
more or less
I lost my whole friend group,
my best friend
that I basically called a brother.
there was moments where he was hurting
years ago with co
and I gave him money for he could have bills paid and his family
wouldn't have to worry
I I cared for him. He he was he said he was moving down here
in
a few months
and he
now know why he he wanted to
what I will say.
>> Dude
oh dude
brutal
>> I lost a lot. >> Oh my god. I lost a lot.
I didn't just like lose
Okay, I just have to point out, bro, the
aura is undefeated.
IT'S ACTUALLY UNDEFEATED. I'm I'm so thankful. I thank my lucky
stars. I don't like little kids. Okay, with the alogging I was
doing a facade, I some terrible [__] would have happened
to me. Okay. Jesus Christ. Another one [laughter] bites the dust,
man. Holy [__]
Holy [__]
H
I b I lost my whole social circle basically just gone.
What really hurts?
Best friend of 10 years.
He knew
He knew my
my life story. He He had I thought he had my back. He He was
there for me with the times of being harassed. And
I viewed him like a brother.
like ask him a brother. Yeah, I got it.
>> He He does that.
I was in a dark place and I've had a lot of dark thoughts.
No, man. No, don't. Come on, man. No, don't have those dark.
No, don't do that.
There's always
You got to see how One Piece ends, man. Come on. Don't do that.
No.
All day. Well, last night I have
I'm gonna be honest, guys.
This is one of the hardest moments for me in my my entire life.
But but
like I I've told you guys many times if you've watched my content,
one of the only joys
in my life I've had over the years
is making content,
talking about what I love.
It is the one
it's never that's never caused me
I just
I did lose
so much. I
just like to point out maybe maybe we're seeing some reasons
why the girlfriend fiance sorry left. There's only one thing
I've loved for the past few years and that's making content.
I don't know. Maybe you could have tried the fiance loving the
fiance. Maybe hypothetically
>> she was he was sending her
and just the
the
Just be honest, man. Just be honest. Be
That got the one ball going for you, didn't it? Reading those
texts that that got his singular ball really going. Okay. got
the testosterone going again. Suddenly he was he was really into
it.
I'm pretty hurt, guys. I'm not going to
I don't know what's going to happen or anything. I really don't.
The future's uncertain right now. I have
I have no idea.
I however am making this video to try to some degree
to cement my thoughts in stone
to be able to process them in my own way
to be able to
try to move
past this just nightmarish
day. I
>> Yeah, like sorry that this is obviously true. They said
they don't like gaming with him. I'm going to say I'm going to
go ahead and say probably they really didn't like you at all.
They probably only tolerated you because of that guy. And they're
like, "Yeah, we
we literally
only liked you because of that guy. We're not going to That's
the only possible thing, right?" Like they just don't like him.
I just
dropped an AirPod. Got to pick it up. I heard that.
Lost the AirPod. AirPod is gone.
Ain't nothing go right today, guys.
>> I'm going to be honest with you guys. I I don't know
what I will do.
I
>> There's two ways. I
>> Have you thought about um drinking and driving again?
>> There's two ways. I either a I don't make videos for
a while
or
I just make videos and I try to black
just black hole everything and just
>> moving and
>> didn't you kind of up that thing? Wouldn't the only
way to do that be by not talking about it and not making it a
thing that's going to get brought up in every single comment
section for the next year and a half?
I feel like this is the one thing that makes it impossible to
just keep making videos
now.
Like everybody is going to keep talking about you. And
hopefully you've told the entire truth here because I swear there's
another possibility that if his entire friend group left that
there was a reason they took those people's side and not his
and he's gone online to lie about it. And if they're the kind
of people who aren't like well thank god he's out of our lives
and we're going to move on. there's a chance that he's lying
about a bunch of right now and they're going to be like, "Well,
I'm not going to let you go on your channel and just lie about
everything." Here's our side of the story. Okay.
So, he better hope that he's actually telling the whole story
here.
Yeah. If he's he could be trying to get ahead of it. If he's
not telling the full story here, he might be totally himself.
Okay?
Cuz there's a chance if nobody says anything and he just makes
content, never mentions it again, that he gets away with whatever's
going on. Because I'll be honest, people are annoying, but I
take I take cheating pretty seriously. And I feel like most people
are the same that like if I'm in a friend group and somebody
cheats on someone else. Even if I don't like the guy who got
cheated on, I'm probably going to be like, "Yeah, I'm not hanging
out with those guys either, though." Like, "No, thank you. That's
kind of that's kind of gay of you, to be honest. You're kind
of somebody that I wouldn't trust."
You know what I mean? I don't care if people treat No, I think
it's uh I think it's behavior.
I I just be like, "Yeah, you're if you're willing to do that
to the person you trust, right? or somebody who's really close
to you, then I I'm not going to be around you. I'm not going
to trust you. I'm going to move on. Right. You're just an untrustworthy
I don't care about cheating. It's slim pickings where I live.
Um
yeah, I don't look at it that way.
I
I just I personally don't think I I personally don't like it.
I think it's like one of the worst things you could do to somebody,
but I also don't know that we're getting the whole story here.
Anyway, not let's not let's not get off on a tangent about something
that's less funny than this guy's life fault part,
>> Just black hole everything and just
keep
moving and
we'll see.
What I will say though,
I thank everyone that's been supportive.
to those out there, you know who you are. You have been
more supportive than I could have ever imagined. So,
I know
I'm just like I said, I'll leave it at
What?
What a year.
I don't know how this is worse than
the anything I've
>> dealt with. I can deal with being harassed online and
stuff. That's >> Wait, was it cancer or was it like a a
hernia or something? How do you lose the
I actually don't know. Wait, is this your music or his? my music,
bro. If he if he put this music in his own sad posting video,
I'd actually have to respect him a little bit. That would be
hilarious portion.
Oh, boys, that's rough, man. I've grown numb to that.
But all of this triple whammy of just everything and then
the betrayals
just
I might
>> seek therapy
>> or something. I don't know.
>> for now I'll leave it at that.
I'm sorry for worrying everybody. I'm
I'm [snorts] still alive
thanks to the efforts of a few individuals. I I'm shocked about
I I do love you guys.
I love you, my community.
I do.
Chibi out,
>> dude. Okay. Chibi out. She be out, boys. She be out.
Well, he isn't your best friend. Yeah, that's true. No one is
loyal anymore. Nick Light came in clutch with the check. Kudos
to the police for the quick response.
Holy [__] dude. Your ex- fiance and ex- best friend
are some up people that destroy trust and love like that. Maybe.
Maybe that's all it is.
I don't Yeah, man. I
I feel like he's probably betting on like them just not being
online enough to clarify.
You know what Chibi should do though? [laughter] He should
he should post a a picture of them standing, you know, from from
20t away. I just want to see Okay.
[laughter] I want to see the person on the other side of this
hand. Okay.
I want to see it, man. I want to see it, man. Come on, man. Show
me. Show me. Show me.
Chippy coming home early with a big five gallon bucket of lard
for his hogw [laughter] wife and noticing his best friend's foot
sticking out from under one of her ferals. Dude.
>> Okay. All right.
All right. All right. Well, that was pretty mean.